Speaker 1: As you of course know, much
of the American Republican Party has now
had as a default view of election integrity. If
we won, there was integrity. But if we lost, there
was fraud and it was rigged. This is the premise
of the Big Lie, as it's called, which emanated
from Donald Trump's loss to Joe Biden back in
November of 2020. Now, more than a year ago
last week before the election in which Republican
Glenn Youngkin defeated Democrat Terry McAuliffe,
you already had some Republicans claiming fraud.
Here's an example I played for you last week.
This is Virginia Republican state senator Amanda
chasing the Democrats are already committing voter
fraud and she knows how.
Speaker 5: Look,
I'm all about fighting for the truth
too, and sometimes, unfortunately,
we can't always rely on the media. I wanted to go
there. I wanted to feel it. I wanted to see it. A
picture is worth a thousand words. I know how
Democrats are cheating, and that information
has been given to the Youngkin campaign.
Speaker 3: Well, they're going to try to do it
in Fairfax County. You know, to me, I'm already
Speaker 5: getting reports today
that people are going to vote and they
have never done a mail in ballot, ever.
And yet when they went to cast their ballot, they
were told, No, we've already mailed you a mail in
ballot. And so we're already looking into that.
Speaker 3: That's that's what we told.
Everybody in Virginia vote early. So
that couldn't happen. The earlier vote,
they couldn't do it. Now they're starting
Speaker 1: to do it. There were other examples,
but you get the idea. But then last week, Glenn
Youngkin won the election. All talk of fraud
ceased. None of them are talking about fraud
anymore. Remember that there's this invisible
sort of like a flowchart. Did the Republican
win? Yes. Then there was no fraud. That's
essentially the way it works. Well, it turns
out there was attempted fraud. Listen to this.
NBC News is reporting that Glenn Youngkin, own 17
year old son twice tried to vote last Tuesday on
Election Day. Even though you can't vote when
you're 17 years old in the U.S., you have to
be 18 to vote. Now, he was not successful in his
attempt to vote. News outlets are not naming him
because he's a minor and he hasn't been charged
with a crime. But by saying Glenn Youngkin,
17 year old son, we know who it is, he showed
up to vote and election workers figured out
he's not eligible to vote. He's not registered
to vote 17 and he was not allowed to vote.
The Fairfax County Office of Elections is
investigating the incident. The Office. A
civil action said in a statement this morning, the
general registrar was made aware of concerns that
a 17 year old male attempted on two occasions to
vote on Election Day. The young man presented ID
but was ineligible to be registered due to his age
and was not permitted to vote. The man was given
a registration form and encouraged to register in
the future. When he's 18 is what that means. Now,
the funniest plot twist would be that he was
trying to register to vote for Terry McAuliffe,
not his own dad. We have no reason to think
that that was the case. In all seriousness,
what sort of funny, but also not really funny, is
that it doesn't actually seem like he committed
a crime because of how the law is written,
even though there are people in other states
who are in prison for accidentally voting when
not eligible. Fairfax County Registrar Scott
Canopus said it's not clear any crime was
really committed because the Virginia Criminal
Code makes it clear if you use fraudulent
information to vote, that's against the law,
but simply trying to vote and being determined
ineligible. That's not clearly addressed in the
Virginia code, and ultimately the quote is the
man did not vote. He made no false statements.
He did not disrupt voting. It appears as though no
actual crime was committed. Now that being said,
remember in Texas, Crystal Mason, who was
previously sentenced to five years in prison
for making a mistake in vote that was not
counted despite being ineligible? That's
Texas. Texas upheld that sentence. We have a
very different situation here in Virginia, but
the people most loudly talking about the fraud
seem to disproportionately be the ones attempting
to commit it. So just a little minor follow up
story there from the Glenn Youngkin election
in Virginia. We're going to take a quick break
and we have much more coming up right after this